all right hello everyone how are you
guys doing hope you guys are having a
wonderful day and today we are here with
episode number 10 of noob with a mill if
you guys don't know what this series is
about I was a noob a long while ago with
one mil in my bank and uh over like the
last probably about two months a little
over we've been working on the account
so uh this is where we're at I didn't
start from level three I started with
some decent stats but our bank is at
90 is at 90 mil on the dot and uh yeah
we got kind of a big merch I'm thinking
right here so these all just like inst
they didn't insta buy but 10,000 just
got dumped on me I'm going to go ahead
and I'm going to make 46 GP per one off
of these so in total I should be making
around a 500K profit but what I do is
instead of getting 500k profit I take
500k back in Eclectic so let's go ahead
and sell these on all right so that
should match about the offer that I had
in so going to go ahead and list those
up that will allow us to yeah as I was
saying keep I guess I didn't get it
exactly right but that allow us to keep
145 eclectics
and in total that brings us up to a
total of 344 in the bank that we have to
do some mediums this episode and another
task just finished up my black demon so
152 gargo that should be pretty good uh
I think we're going to go ahead and get
60 farming maybe yeah nice all right we
going to get 60 farming I'm going to go
check up in my G real quick before I go
to bed so let's go and look at that all
right now that we're at the GE I will
show you guys I have pretty much sold
off half of my eclectics actually a
little more than half so we have that
done for I'm going to go ahead and see
what the margin is currently on them uh
I'll just wait I think they'll go back
up so we'll see what I can sell one on
for all right that's not a bad margin
but what we're actually going to look
for is use saplings we're going to go
ahead and buy and sell one of these all
right that's that's not realistic I
don't think I think you should be able
to at least buy a use sapling all right
bought a use sapling for
80k and as you can see we sell it off
for 75 which means there's a pretty big
margin which means I I think it's closer
to the lower one but as you guys can see
here UCS insta buy for 74.9 we're not
worrying about the insta Buy price and
they sell on for 71.6 so I'm going to
put in an offer for that and uh yeah
we're just going to buy out a ton of uh
U seeds now we are done with Heroes
Quest so there we go one Quest point and
just a lot of random XP nothing to speak
of though probably going to have to go
and get some thieving levels though here
soon for a another Quest all right time
to get another task so going to go ahead
and get this got done with our gargo so
ABY specs not too bad we are currently
merching eclectics again they have 100
GP margin and right now I've bought
5,000 so that could be a 500K margin
which would be about you know 150 150
eclectics and uh just finish off our
abber inspector Tas time to get another
one and Chaos Elemental this is actually
this is actually something I'm pretty
excited about because I want a safe spot
this so we'll go ahead and get 35 uh
that's actually like 1 nth of the uh
drop rate so I like that little bit of
late night merching but went ahead sold
off all the eclectics I ended up gaining
probably around 200 from that I believe
and uh yeah on top of that we also
merched off some odium Shard 3es we
bought them for 2.45 so off for 2.75 so
good 600k profit there I'm going to show
you guys how many eclectics we now have
in the bank so about to hit 600 which
means we got about 1.8 milish in
eclectics to 1.9 and going to go ahead
and buy and sell some more now don't
really know what what else I expected
all right so there we go finished up a
little merch almost so we bought about
10.7 eclectics and as you guys can see
over here we sold on about 10.4 which
means we profited probably about 260 to
300ish somewhere in there and as far as
total eclectics we have now or I guess
it was 242 right there as far as total
eclectics we have now we have 1,00 so
that's a ton I almost feel bad at this
point that all I'm all I'm showing you
guys is eclectic
merchesi bought well 10.8k I bought for
37.8 mil and I sold them all on for as
you can see here 38.9 I'm going to go
ahead and use that 1.1 mil to uh
reinvest in them I forgot to actually
keep them just going to kind of go
through what I've been up to so I just
woke up but uh bought oh my God I bought
300 almost 268 ued so that's a ton we're
going to see what we can sell them off
in sapling form for but on top of that
as far as your collectic goes you guys
can see here
18.7 for all of those I ended up buying
them for 18.3 so I have about 470k to go
ahead and spend on eclectics and uh
before I was buying U seeds for 73k as
you guys saw and I was able to sell out
43 for 80.5 which means I made 72k on
all of these which means I made
somewhere a little over 300K off of that
so going to go ahead take everything out
and as you guys can see the cash T that
I have right now it's looking pretty
good we also have a ton of U seeds and
as you guys can see that is 20 m alone
right there and that is it for the chaos
Elemental Tas so no pet but uh I guess I
kind of understand the safe spot more
which is really good uh I made a video
on it displaying it but there are
problems every now and then that you can
mess up and so it does kind of take some
practice so getting good with that but
let's go get another task just want to
go ahead and show you guys how much
money I made uh yeah you know just what
I like to do but sold off all of these U
saplings I sold them I guess I'll show
you guys this here in a second then time
for another task hoping for a Jad task
maybe that'd be cool no black demons all
right well AFK and some strength XP
closing in on 93 which is really nice
and earlier I showed you guys how I was
merching U saplings or U seeds as you
guys can see there sold them all off for
pretty much 80k and it doesn't show it
here oh it does I bought them for 73k so
I made about 7K on each one of these so
in total that is just that that's a ton
of money I mean realistically I think
it's like 2.7 2.8 or 1.7 to 1.8 mil so
that's a really nice profit right there
and going to go ahead and try try to get
more of that all right so I haven't made
any Clips in a while but you guys will
get kind of an overview as to what's
going on here so earlier I sold off some
eclectics as you guys can see I bought
them for this and uh sold them or sold
some off for about 140 GP profit which
isn't too bad so we made about 120k or
so there and then I sold off the rest
you guys I don't think can see it for
some reason but I sold off the rest for
around a 50 GP profit so in total off
the 50 in the in the
120ish just so many numbers but probably
made around
300K uh Rune darts as you guys can see I
bought a ton of them for
1127 and ended up selling them all on
for a 50 GP profit so in total there
that could be around 5 to 600k but I did
have some that I kind of failed earlier
so I'd saywhere around four to five and
uh something that I guess you guys can
also see here is the insul dragon heads
I was making about 120 GP off of each
one and in total of day I probably
flipped like 3,000 or so so we made
around 360k is there and also UT tree
seeds I don't have any pictures of them
but I probably made a good 5K off of 200
earlier which got me a mill so there is
that and we ended up selling off all of
our eclectics I don't know how many were
sold off during the last uh picture that
I had with you guys or the last the last
picture what the hell am I saying the
last [__] the last clip god I'm an
idiot right now I don't know what's
going on but 93 GP margin as you guys
can see in the bank I have the
collection of eclectics and we are up to
1.6k I'm going to eventually save up and
just make a video at like a really big
number of eclectic so yeah I mean it's
going to take a while to do that video
but yeah so I'm going to uh just merge
some more of these why not right we'll
we'll we'll undercut this guy because
I'm feeling it and another update so we
sold on a ton of unold dragon heads we
made a 100
made 120 GP off of all these well each
one so in total we made like 24K also
have a ton of eclectics that I bought
over here so yeah 4.2 or 4.7 th000 I
don't even know where I was going with
that uh s and brw have a huge margin
right now um so hopefully I can take
advantage of that I don't know why and
as far as a collectic scale I think
they're buying for Med which uh seems a
little weird so I'm going to go ahead
and leave but I'm going to list them in
for 35 85 if I go ahead and do that
that'll mean that we're making I think
75 GP off of each one yeah 77 GP so
that'd be a good like little over 300K
profit so we'll take that finished up a
couple clues so we got a medium and a
hard I think I'll open the medium first
since that'll probably be depressing and
uh nailed that one so uh time for the
hard clue and nothing really going on
here so that was rough I hate myself so
much I'm just I'm I'm
enjoying merch ing so much right now and
you may think like oh that's not a bad
thing but there's barely any content to
get out of this that's the problem is I
mean there's not much to say unless I
come back every like 20 seconds with
another update on how I made 100K but if
you guys want to look here you guys can
kind of get an idea as to what I was up
to so as you guys can see I was able to
buy and sell off a ton of jars for about
140 GP margin I had a ton earlier yeah
as you can see right there so I probably
made close to 7800k off of all of them
um some insult dragon heads that I was
buying for 11k as you can see my
inventory I have a little over a th000
now I probably made about 3 to 400k
today off of doing those maybe more and
as you can see there I sold 8.4 th000
eclectics for 3.5k I bought them or 3.57
that's important because I bought them
all for around 3.5 so I made 70 GP off
of each one of them which you know in
total gets me 5 to 600k so I've just
been doing a lot of that probably made a
couple M today but that's just a small
little update for you and here we are
did a little bit of merching so I sold
off all of my dragon heads which is
really good uh I probably made about 250
coins off of all these which got us
about 300K or so um I just bought 8,000
eclectics because it was a really good
price on them so I figured why not and I
recently released a video so if they
happen to go up at all because of that
I'm down but even if not I mean that's
that's not the plan they have a really
good price right now and as you guys can
see 359 7 I can make 110 GP per one
which means that I think I'll be making
almost like 900k if I was able to sell
them all right now uh then from there
impling jars uh impling jars are kind of
weird apparently they peaked recently
and that's why I'm able to buy them for
this low um I was hoping that I could
just actually you know kind of make some
good money off of it but as you guys can
see I am able to make about 74 GP off of
all these which would leave us with
around another 800k profit so I mean in
total like 1.6 mil but not too bad at
all little bit of postc com coming at
you guys but I made 1.8 mil on all these
merchesi to say this in the future this
episode was filled with a lot of small
merchesi level for you just finished up
a huge merch as you guys can see here so
75 mil 72.2 2.8 mil profit not bad and
there we go nice little profit off of a
kod i w so as you guys can see able to
make about 1.4 mil on that and didn't
take anywhere near like half an hour to
do so I'll take that so as I do merching
the kod iws like a boss made another 1.4
mil Easy Money easy money and uh just
like that another one sold on so if we
look back here at the history we got we
got a nice little string of Kodi WS here
I think so uh 1.4 mil made off of all
these I don't know yeah no we had the
third age play legs it was a 2.7 mil
merch yesterday and then so far 1.4 mil
merch is on three Kodi wands which
brings us up to 4 2 today so we are on a
nice little merching grind I don't know
if the margin's really here cuz that
took me a while to sell all those so I'm
going to go ahead or to sell the last
one so I'm going to go ahead and
probably switch up items I'm about to
Rapid Fire this [__] off let's get ready
so fishing level right there we made
500k and a Cod iwan not too bad at all
went ahead and made ourselves 1.7 mil on
some third age lades an agility level
another 1.8 milish on I think that was
2.2 boom fishing level back to the
merching Grind so as you guys can see
here Elder Maul just ended up merching
it for
1.17 milish so almost 1.2 mil which is
definitely nice and uh going to try to
do some probably third age plate legs
I'd imagine but uh right now nothing's
really got too big of a margin and uh
another day another merch so went ahead
and merched on an elder mall for 1.2 mil
really nice stuff there got a uh bunch
of insult demon heads selling off
they're going for about 140 GP profit so
that's about to be about 160k or so
nothing too much but uh that's what we
got going on right now and uh yeah just
sold off an elder mall I'm currently
selling off a ton of my bank to go ahead
and merch D claws right now which I
actually have a really good margin so
we're going to go ahead and do that if
you look at the bottom made a 900k off
30h plate legs also
made like 1.5 mil on an elder Mall merch
right there went ahead and merched on
another Elder Maul for 1.3 mil and I
made 1.3 mil on the eternal glory as
well so celebrated with buying a book of
law I don't say this in the future
though but I did end up buying another
Elder ma that I tried to merch didn't do
[__] with that so I took it to chaos
Elli I end up losing a lot of money on
the mall I'll talk about that here in a
second but got a dragon pickaxe pretty
pissed I couldn't cut this web and
there's the loss so all right so as you
guys saw in the last clip I did actually
manage to lose a lot on the Elder Mall
you guys can't see it anymore cuz I had
to sell off some stuff but I think I
lost about 2.1 mil on that so that was
definitely really rough uh I could have
sold it on earlier today for a 5 mil
loss and I was considering it but in my
head I was like maybe it'll come back up
I could sell it right now if I would
have sold it now I would have only lost
one mil but I'm happy at where I sold it
off because as you guys can see up here
merged some Dragon claws I'm gonna kind
of run through them with you guys real
quick so off of this one we made a cool
600k then uh made a little more on this
next one about 650k then we got some big
margins on these two so we got 1.4 mil
there and 1.3 mil there so in total I
think we ended up making what 1.3 1.4
and then 13 pretty much so I think we
made about 4 mil back which means we've
definitely recouped the loss we had on
our Eld all and also made about 2 mil on
top of that so I'm really happy with
that going to try to keep merching these
but the uh the margin's kind of gone
down a lot so uh not looking too good
right now but definitely happy last time
you see me in postom love you guys but
random trolls Tas there we
go and I am back so one and got got some
pretty balling gear like look at me out
here but then I got the combat bracelet
on man maybe one day maybe one day I'll
get the quest points for some barrows
gloves but but for now time to get
another task and uh yeah that doesn't
sound like anything I want to do right
now so considering we have the points to
do so I'm going to go ahead and skip
that because you know I can I can do
that and uh we got Anu so there we go
damn that's a nice pet though and as you
do went ahead and finished up my Slayer
test so done with that anus are over
giant mole I've never killed giant mole
but I'll say 35 cuz that wait [__] would
it be worth it to kill 35 cuz isn't the
way you're supposed to do this with der
I guess why not we'll go and do 35 that
sounds like a good time and there is the
start of recipe for disaster so not
necessarily working on this that much
now I just need to go ahead and do mole
and uh want to go ahead and use derck so
I'm going to need a rock cake all right
so I've been streaming and so the things
I've done previously will not be in this
video as I accidentally actually had
music in the background but just got
done doing a little bit of wintert got
up to 7 fire making only one real level
there we're going to go ahead and open
up some crates and as you guys can see I
get [__] all because oh not [__] all we
get something but yeah that's really
nice going to go ahead and bank that
I'll show you guys what I've been doing
at the Grand exchange real quick and
then we'll go ahead and end off this
video
because it's time for another [__]
episode to start man it's a new week
kind of so uh yeah I mean a little bit
of merching we did earlier so as you
guys can see here we merched on a
torture or some tortures for 500k profit
there we merched this abital bludgeon
said that really weird this Abyssal
budgeon for 250k and then we bought
another two which we've been trying to
sell off but they have not sold because
I suck it merching so I think they
actually should be selling for around
this price I'm just going to leave them
in but yeah all right well just finished
off another little merch so give me a
second and it was an ancestrial hat that
I bought last night for 4.72 and sold on
4 point or 40 okay so I bought it for
47.2 sold on for 48. s so we made 1.5
mil on that really good margin there but
that's going to be it for this episode
so going to finish this all off real
quick go ahead and check the bank value
as you guys can see we've definitely
made a lot of progress this episode with
all the
merchesi bank value and calculate and we
are up
to 134 mil so that is insane we've
definitely made a ton of progress this
episode I don't know what I started off
with but that's definitely an
improvement and we are just killing it
right now with the money that I have
it's we're just going to keep making
exponentially more since I the more
money I get the more stuff I can merch
and just the more margins I'll be able
to take over so that'll be it for this
episode hope you guys enjoyed if you
guys did make sure to leave a like as
always uh subscribed if you really enjoy
the content and you guys can check out
07 helpers in game just a little Clan
chat I chilling so come by say Hi also
hit up the Twitter in the description
but with that being said hope you guys
have a wonderful day and peace [__] off
Chelsea this is [__]
[Music]
[__]